[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so this is a recently open source
project that we built at uber to tackle
some specific use cases that we had
which are going to as well as broadly
bringing incremental process
incrementals onto Hadoop and will as we
see we will see why we haven't at all
all of this so quick show of hands
everyone's familiar with kuru spark in
this room how many you guys so okay and
how many ask you guys have written a
data pipeline like in any MapReduce Park
anything okay cool so I'll try to go a
little faster in like basic areas sweet
so first of all I'm gonna um so I'm I'm
on the data infrastructure platform team
at uber so broadly worked mostly on data
infrastructure for the past 10 years
give or take agenda for today so we'll
do a quick tour of data tuber like how
vu all very very short then we'll look
into motivations for why we built this
project you know get into some concepts
that you know our key to the design of
the project deeper dive into design and
implementation look at few use cases
what it can solve what it's also doober
and finally compare and contrast with
few other like approaches and data
systems that exist out already and talk
about generally open source how we are
you know what plans do we ha what's a
roadmap on how we can be a part of it so
data Dober I'm going to recap basically
a story of roughly three years so we
started with I think as every other
company started and even like the
company before uber I worked on I'll go
through similar trajectory so we had
like unreliable data so you know JSON
data like people talking to each other
about what schemas are for the datasets
and we did not have not so unless the
business grows you don't know what the
scaling points would be to some degree
so we had a lot of scaling
problems we had like we did not have
Hadoop yet we had Kafka 7 and our data
volumes were growing and you know we
were getting into multi data center use
cases where the mergers weren't like the
darker textured couldn't handle merging
data between multiple data centers and
the data couldn't just flow that way and
again we have like a lot of
inefficiencies we had several large
subsidies and data and we were doing
bulk data copies from you know LDP
systems and stressing them in the
process and we just had one single
choice for query engine Vertica which is
what you use to query all of data so
fast forward I think from our humble
beginnings we've gotten to a point where
we've you know where we had this we had
built built like a beautiful bridge so
Avro is the lingua franca of data this
is again like something that comes from
LinkedIn company that I worked for
before and works really well in practice
the infor schema producer side so got
rid of a lot of the reliability problems
data all of our infrastructure scales
horizontally um nothing very innovative
about this we just you know rapidly move
our stack towards these technologies and
like sort of did caught this up to like
kind of open source standards basically
and yeah most of raid assets are now at
one to three hours latency will go into
you know a lot of cases as to why and
and hoody even tries to push this lower
than one to three minutes and we have
multiple query engine support depending
on the use case and who are our users
users our analytics League of
bread-and-butter analytics you want to
do interactively analyze the data data
signs and you know data apps so machine
learning detecting fraud and trying to
figure out safe driving patterns and so
forth unn standard Baro Singh detailing
curating feeds from Hadoop on to like
you know warehouse like Vertica are good
moving it into mem sequel for more
real-time going things like that and
across these the query
we picked our presto for most of the you
know analytics or interactive querying
use cases and spark is how we write data
pipelines and generally complex you know
algorithms which do machine learning or
all of these like you know data
crunching and high-vis are like
bread-and-butter way to build the data
warehouse and express like you know
traditional ETL batch pipelines so
motivations is what is look at next so
basically the thing that we got from our
users we heard loud and clear after we
put together like these query engines
and sort of built up the like the
standard Hadoop you know stack is we
want faster data across all of these use
cases because of the nature of uber
business is since we touch a lot of the
physical world things change the
physical world and there is a like a lot
of business value and reflecting it
quickly into our like kind of analytical
or warehouse ecosystem as well and one
specific problem which I'm going to kind
of use to motivate why we build the
project is our you know bread-and-butter
sort of scripts pipeline so what happens
here is every 30 minutes we get a bunch
of new data basically new types bunch of
updates to existing trips and the
problem here is so we do typically what
you do in Hadoop to store data which is
to partition it by some time like a day
or an hour sometimes some fee and the
problem here was the updates there are
some you know new data as you can see by
the blue boxes there is some lot of
updated data for the current day but the
updates go well beyond the current day
even crossing a like a you know few
months even into the past
this means all the traditional
techniques that people typically used to
deal with this in Hadoop are okay will
rewrite the partition will rewrite like
the entire table those sort of things
cannot don't work and in fact we
actually started doing something which
the status quo in database ingestion
today which is okay have a database you
somehow managed to scrape logs into
Kafka you get those logs you kind of
build a replica closer to your vassals
in this case HBase table and at this
point you know HBase is like effectively
a read replica of your know upstream
database and we also log these updates
onto HDFS for sort of like safekeeping
but ultimately what we do is we then
snapshot this entire you know multi
table by data set on to something like
Parque a file format which is like
really suited for analytics and all
downstream consumers then recompute
their own derivatives based off of that
and needless to say I mean we know if we
recompute on the full data for all of
these data sets we won't have capacity
right so people do approximations and
like guesses on to what portion of the
data is actually changing you know going
back to the previous slide we make like
assumptions on okay this table is only
going to have updates till last week
like last two days sort of things like
that right so we kind of but ultimately
though this snapshot grew and grew as
uber grew and grew it went to like 800
executors and it still took 8 hours to
finish and then you know by August feel
like completely redlining it was
withdrawn like thousand and thousand
five plus executors at this still was
taking you know 10 knots there's a
running joke inside uber that if we let
this go like this it will become
petabyte one day and we can't write a
blog about how we have a petabyte
pipeline but but I don't think the
ecosystem will survive so you know we
thought of or okay fine how do you fix
this again standard ways okay oh why not
query HBase yes we can accept HP is not
actually really suited for analytical
queries like to be used as your prime
time you know query system right because
and it does not have support for nested
data something that we have and
something that parque and like Wars even
supports really well and again it's not
doesn't come
free you to in order to like have HBase
support a core data set like trips at
Hoover you need to actually operate
HBase at a scale that is equivalent to
HDFS unless you can do that your H base
region servers are simply not going to
be able to deal with the i/o load I'll
go into little more of this sort of you
know more down the line and okay why not
use specialized analytical databases
they're like awesome for their purposes
a lot of them store data in memory but
in this case what the problem we are
solving for is we on a store all the
data like all the clips for uber right
so it's so we can't keep all the data in
memory and again we get into you know
okay even if you put these two datasets
into this specialized data store you
still have other datasets in HDFS you
need to cross join against and it's not
a very simple problem to solve so okay
what can we do here like okay let's not
support snapshots so give people only
logs right okay fine
easy right problems all but no you only
push the problem down to your user logs
need to be compacted so even Kafka has a
log compaction feature right so I mean
if you don't solve this at this level
users are only going to merge these logs
themselves in consistently and
inefficiently and I don't think like
we're not going to be able to control
you know the efficiency of the entire
ecosystem okay can we do something with
the data model where we can like you
know change this the Saran sir here is
no because fundamentally if you have
late data and you wanted reflected in
your derived tables then yes you need to
deal with this it does not go away so
then we you know sort of this force just
to come back to the real question that
we were sort of dancing around which is
okay can we solve this directly on HDFS
like using in on Hadoop data Lake and
what is it take to actually solve this
right
to answer this we went a decade back
because this problem is very familiar
it's it's not very very new problem
right how did our DBMS actually do this
if you take like some changes coming
into my sequel you typically just update
my sequel table you pull some changes
from a redo log you do whatever
transformations that you want to do and
you update it back into my sequel right
so this is how the data CDC the data
integration space work even today and I
think the key differences here are we
are dealing with petabytes of data
across thousands of servers and you know
columnar file formats and so the problem
is conceptually little bit the same but
I think the manifestation inside Hadoop
is little bit different right so we got
our answer so we need to essentially
support a storage abstraction on top of
HDFS which will let us do efficient
absurds
and then incremental pooling where we
know okay given a point in time what was
updated
so essentially streaming parameters if
we can support on top of HDFS data sets
then we'll be able to kind of like just
solve the problem that I'm like we
solved now but as well as sort of you
know holistically have a chance to
improve the entire ecosystem in terms of
efficiency so here is what we did got
rid of the dump it's like you know we
would have no intentions for a petabyte
scale blog post so we built an absurd
perimeter which basically can achieve
this absurd in 30 minutes is 100
executors today and we are moving
towards 5 minute with 50 executors that
will talk about this more as we get into
hoody so once we have this we built and
like you know with a some extra metadata
tracking and whatnot we are able to you
know it just it takes just 2 minutes to
ask what are the tips that got updated
or like you know inserter in the last
one are so now this gives the drive
table like
essentially the remaining 50 we add
minutes to be able to build these
derivatives as well so most importantly
now these tables become more accurate
they're not like approximations anymore
so everyone can so if you find a trip in
the base table then you can find the
trip on the same derived table right so
that that carries a lot of value because
these tables are actually again cross
joint in some cases ultimately we have
presto users unlike our you know city
ops people who are major customers of
our data very happy because now they get
fresh data and ecosystem wise we are
using 10xx
executors so okay so at this point what
we've seen so far is like a
manifestation of a problem at uber how
we solved it and I want to take a little
bit of time here to motivate some of the
more theoretical like concepts in
whatever we saw like here right so to
try to kind of understand this a little
bit more in an abstract way before we
dive into sort of like hoodie and the
internal guts of it okay let's simply
start with understanding a data pipeline
in a very theoretical way so it's
ultimately it just boils down to reading
from a source doing some transformations
writing it back to sync whether you are
doing stream processing very reading
from cough card doing stream processing
writing it back into Cassandra you know
Kafka back or whatever or you're doing a
standard ETL pipeline I'm reading from
Hadoop writing it back into Vertica it
doesn't matter it's the same kind of
abstract problem right and then
ultimately what you will do is such
combination of these operations
projections and filtering very very easy
anyone any engine can do this really
well row based transformations
aggregations and windowing a little bit
tricky but it needs some stateful
processing in terms of like you know
what are the window links and whatnot
and then when you like join a lot of
these individual tables then things card
start to get like really hard right
and operationally you have essentially
these lures for a data pipeline so this
is directly borrowed from the Google
data flow paper which i think is one of
the papers which makes like most sense
in terms of conceptually understanding a
data pipeline
so essentially you want all of this done
at some latency are not some correctness
or completeness of your results and when
we talk about correctness there is
actually like a you know balance between
latency and correctness especially if
you take late-arriving data or joins you
are joined to kafka streams in a stream
passing where it is a little bit tricky
but it's practical but if you do want to
do a six-way join then it becomes like
much harder of a problem right so most
people you know do the trade-offs where
they kind of pick two out of three you
can achieve all three if you want for
simpler pipe links or by spending lot
more cost so a very common way to build
data by plane slammed architecture right
so you have a speed layer ways where you
do some of these more simpler processing
on user the you know the simpler data
but at like you know much reduced
latency you may take a hit on
completeness as I said in some of these
cases then you do more complex
transformations and more complete may be
complete calorie calculation of the same
results in a batch way and then move it
into like another serving store and the
layer merges both and that's that's I
think being the norm for a long time now
in terms of data processing and there
are some theoretical reasons why but
overall what this has led to is like
there is a forced dichotomy here where
we are like used to thinking about data
by influences extreme and batch and I
think in reality it's actually a
spectrum even at uber when we looked at
our data pipelines you know we have the
one-minute level ones there are like
very very few right where a very few
were
we say a surge is one like yeah one
minute we are recomputing surge and like
what not but Allah a lot of use cases
extracted that 10 minute line if you are
extract doing dashboards you may like
sacrifice your completeness little bit
to get like more fresh metrics to see
what's going on and ask you like goat
more towards a completeness line like be
fraud was one of the motivating use
cases to build hoodie to begin with so
we have complex joints there so we want
to run like incremental job on Hadoop
where we are detecting fraud or we want
to do faster ETLs are complete you know
something that we are computing how much
incentive like a partner has earned so
those things need more completeness it
can take a little bit you know latency
more right and then you have the classic
path use cases but across the board what
we saw was hey we have for every
streaming pipeline we have a hundred
batch pipelines right so us and there is
enormous value in actually like making
sure we have faster batch data
unlike batch pipelines can run more
efficiently and more quickly so that we
can like you know things that don't need
a lot of you know sub real-time
latencies can actually move into the
incremental part and some of the
expensive bass wavelengths can come into
the incremental mode and that's I think
like from a business standpoint that's
such basically where we're trying touchy
we are trying to make batch more
efficient and streaming a little bit you
know the cases are it needed for 10 to
15 minutes we move into this mode but it
again we can be more efficient so what
do we really mean by in criminal
processing is essentially running mini
batch pipelines but in a streaming
fashion so when you run mini bus
pipelines you get higher completeness
than your typical streaming pipelines
and since you do it in a streaming
fashion which means you are only acting
on new input and you are able to update
old results you get like faster latency
than your TP
right so effectively we basically filled
the gap that we were observing and then
made it more of a spectrum of choices
that you pick based on your use case
rather than being a you know sort of a
dichotomy I as I mentioned and I could
quickly go through some of the reasons
why we did this so increase efficiency
if you run em so take this example if
you have events coming at 10k per second
you want to count the number of events
in the last 10 minutes at 15 minutes in
all latency then if you run a stream
processing job it's going to keep
updating some result or like heck space
or whatever constantly but you can just
run a job which takes five minutes in
batch grabs more resources it can
compute Madhu all the count merges in
memory and just just one update right so
on-demand resource allocation and lesser
IO are both like big wins and again we
can leverage all the hadoop sequel
engines columnar files formats like
parquet and they already cover a wide
range of use cases as I mentioned before
and again like this simplifying the
architecture so you can run these more
faster pipelines on the same batch
infrastructure that you are used to
building your you know like all of these
other tons of pipelines so what do we
need again to just do this on top of
your Hadoop stack is absurd they help
you modify process resource they're like
state source and stream processing an
incremental pool which is okay you get a
log of changes and you can avoid costly
scans to just know what has changed in a
table so with this
finally we formally introduced hoodie he
stands for Hadoop absurds on
incrementals it's a storage abstraction
to apply mutations to a data set and
then pull change locks incrementally
basically implements both these
primitives it's a spark library scales
are so it scales that is only just like
another job so that's
the distinguishing feature in terms of
we ran up to write for a storage system
separates which has to be stay scale
like you know HBase or something
open-source you can find us here here
and effectively you know what this looks
like is you take a change lock you up
sewed it into large HDFS data set then
it becomes a normal high table which you
can access by a high restore spark in
addition you can also like do an
incremental query which will give you
only the you know changed rows as of a
given kind commitment so if you if
you're familiar with even time and
arrival time concepts in stream
processing the change log is basically
giving you data off of like you're sort
of arrival time and then your standard
queries runoff even time so very high
level what hoody is is you ember a
hoodie right client which is like a
spark library into your spark job and
then provide an RDD containing the data
that you want to store an index so this
data then goes into basically gets
indexed where we map a record to a file
containing the record and then data
files where we actually store these data
sets and then some timeline metadata to
basically help us implement things like
you know change lock so timeline
metadata stores all the activities that
are rights and all of them background
activity everything that's happening to
a data store it's like a redo log and
how we actually store unlike index and
layout this data is what we call as a
storage type and then the part about
reading data then you know like I said
it can happen why a high restore spark
and this is what we call as like set of
views so so the idea is again storage
types define how the data is stored then
views then like give you a few tables on
hive with like different trade-offs to
actually read the data that you've
written so for example you have
two storage types one is like called
copy-on-write which will quickly look
into how its implemented but it provides
read optimized view which is like
essentially purely columnar backed by
pathway data and it also provides a log
view which essentially implements the
incremental polling capability
so the one that we are moving towards in
the future is merge and read that gives
you in addition to the other two views
it gives you a more real-time view where
it lets you query on the more recent
data and by merging the you know a
columnar and row based file formats on
the fly okay so now we're getting like
you know we've seen the concepts unlike
sort of why we built it all the
motivation now we are going to take a
quick tour into sort of the design and
implementation of like you know these
primitives and I'm going to quickly go a
little quick here so feel free to swing
by the office arts and you know we can
go deeper and do any of this area
situation so basic idea is we have a
partitioned data set on his DFS like you
know date partitioned let's take one
partition on one file right so we have
say pure Park a data set at this point
there are some updates that have to be
applied onto this file so all the
copy-on-write storage does is we added
an index to figure out where these
updates should go to and then we simply
rewrite this file with the versioning so
with new records like sort of add like
rewritten so essentially we are
versioning files underneath and if you
lose simple math if you have these many
partitions this 100 GB per partition and
we block align the files to 128 MB which
is sort of our HDFS block size and we
have 800 files for partition aprox and
we have a workout that spread across you
know a single record that will touch
these many partitions these many files
have to be rewritten every sort of
three minutes and it takes 20 seconds to
rewrite one file with hundred executors
this comes down to 24 minutes this is
basically the first absurd number that
you saw so now this is copy and write
write this gives you like pure Park a
performance that the reason why we went
here first as a first step was we are
moving a big ecosystem towards like a
new storage format so we wanted to make
it very non disruptive to the existing
queries right so now what we are
attempting to do with merge and read is
we are taking 10 GB batches and we don't
know like you know apply it every five
minutes like we want to like do more
incrementally so at this point rewriting
the file is not going to work the write
amplification is like too high so we
introduce a log or attach a log to every
each one of these files and whenever the
log reaches a sufficient size we do the
same thing again which is like we
compact the park' on the log and we
produce any you know file right and goes
on so here we will cut down the write
amplification and we are only like
rewriting 18 files in average based on
how we run the compactor and this so
it's going to leave a lot of data kind
of uncompacted in like older partitions
which are kind of not touched by queries
a lot anyway so we more aggressively
contact the recent data that's that's
sort of what we do and by this we are
able to bring you know the ecosystem
into like you know five ten minutes
which is like great because a lot of our
tools and lot of the Hadoop sequel
engines now have access to fresh uh data
right so I think I'm going to like just
quickly go over all of these so index
again like some it's very pluggable it
basically Maps the record to a file
we have bloom filter and something based
on headspace and then in terms of
storage we are there to the Hadoop file
system abstraction so whatever cloud
storage system which is consistent has
like same consistent guarantees as HDFS
and can you can write files on to we we
can the Kuti can Storify
there let me go quickly over these I
want to get I'll quickly go or the API
so in terms of spark job that you want
to write you Nisha is the who declined
with our context on some convex then you
essentially say start commit it's like a
database you know commit like opening
transaction sort of thing it gives you a
handle then you give it like I said RDD
of Records with the no-handed commit
time and then you it can explicitly
choose to like commit the data so when
we say commit this is like be by
leveraging hedge DFS's
like sort of atomic move we atomically
publish the data to the query so either
commit succeeded or it did not the query
will never see partial data that's
another key thing that we added to like
you know HDFS where I think before in
just processors can fail like in the
middle of moving files and there'll be
like some data that could be copied
while some is not copied and then we
support rollback since we have notion of
comments we can roll it back cool so we
kind of saw the storage type little bit
let's look at the views quickly like I
said like you know sort of two major
views in terms of trading off between
data latency and query kind of latency
query execution time the read optimize
takes a hit on the data latency while it
is like really you know optimized for
analytical or columnar queries while the
real-time tries to you know take a takes
a little bit hit on the query execution
time due to the use of a hybrid of
columnar and row based data sets row
file format sorry but it is it pushes
the data latency down to a large degree
right unlock views simply a special view
which uses the metadata and just simply
pulls records out of storage cool so
let's go back to you know what is how
these views are implemented and like for
this we go back to our old
you know right slide so a view is simply
like a table and hype and if you know hi
so there is an input format where you
have two things basically one is get
splits but it gives you the files that
you want to read uh splits you wanna
read and there is a record reader which
does the actual i/o with the file right
so what we effectively have done is
written customer input formats with
override get splits unlike get record
reader so the read optimized file does
not even look at the log files at all
right all it'll do is it will group
files by the ID and pick the latest
version which is committed which is like
a commit but the real time table
essentially is going to read the you
know the latest Park a file latest
accompanying log file containing
unmerged it changes and then going to
merge it on the fly and then return the
results back so again so you get both
tables if you do much under it so if you
have you can even join the read optimize
table of the real time table if you
choose to
we simply you know exposing to store it
two ways of like looking at the data but
into and we've just organizing it better
differently so we can provide both
essentially an incremental log
essentially we'll look at the commitment
of data and simply you know it knows bad
things got changed and it's going to
simply you know pull pull it with the
metadata that we have so this is like a
benchmark showing for parkade the
performance mention or like the goal
that we set was no degradation from like
versus like a raw park a data set this
this is the major motivation for
copy-on-write on as you can see pretty
much across all of our production
queries we are on par and again to
explain the incremental log view little
bit more going back to our example you
know the incremental log looks at the
timeline metadata
where it knows a single commit has
touched what partitions and what files
and based on that it can essentially
pull across partitions very very
efficiently otherwise you doctors can
say the last year's data over and over
again every our to actually figure out
what purpose change and that's
essentially how we implemented this all
right use cases
so let's first understand abstractly
like sort of where 2d can fit in so like
Julian was saying we can use hoodie to
sort of quickly replicate an online
database or Kafka or any online like log
events quickly into HDFS so your OLAP
world is in sync with your old DP world
at like seven or ten minutes then you
can build incremental data pipelines
once you ingest a data quickly thanks to
incremental pool you know what has
changed so you can keep kind of running
your derived or your ETL pipelines every
sort of you know ten minutes whatever
and you can keep you know pulling new
[Music]
increments and at this point it just
becomes a standard stream stream join or
stream fact stream you know dataset join
in spark streaming terms or in you know
old school sort of virus terms it's more
like fact dimension joints but
effectively it's the same thing you can
choose to put tables either in a
streaming mode in terms of whether you
incremental II pull it or you can choose
to scan it as you would normally do but
you are now able to build these
incremental pipelines with all the
parameters that we provided and so at
this point so you know enterprise
software right so what happens is there
is a system which is unique very popular
then it has some shortcomings of the ton
of systems built around that then
eventually there is a catch-up phase
where a lot of these things are kind of
you know pushed back into the original
system so in those in the spirit of the
hut essentially now
previously you would take you come to
Hadoop only for few hours of data right
because the ingestion is bulk and the
data simply won't even be there so if
the data is not even there you're not
going to be able to process the data
within an hour right so but right now
since we're doing this we can use a
hoodie table on HDFS as like sort of
mainstay for most of our you know batch
and near real-time
use cases adoption uber so we are
powering all our main data injection
into Hadoop via hoodie and this is
happening every 30 minutes today and we
are doing every several terabytes per
hour and we are moving very aggressively
towards less than ten minutes in the
next few months an incremental ETL
tables we have a few in QTL tables which
are like you know sort of like I showed
incremental e built off of hurry and
overall from a more platform perspective
we've managed to reduce the resource
usage by more than 10x so the graph on
the top shows you that like the latency
difference between bulk load and what we
were able to achieve with hoody just
with copy and write so that number is
going to drop even more when we do
margin tree and this is the overall
compute savings that we gained by doing
like incremental absurds are supposed to
bulk loading it's fairly obvious so all
right one of the reasons I was moving
will quickly us I want to spend a little
bit more time on the comparisons so what
grade offs are we making here compared
to other systems right so before we go
too far into that let's first understand
some like basic you know numb like
benchmarks this is a recent benchmark
produced by CERN in terms of comparing
different Hadoop storage formats for
scan performance so as you can see part
K clearly still like comes out on top
you can see the point I was making about
HBase before and then kuru is like
pretty you know pretty close to Parker
but still that is if you look at
GZ which is what we use that is like a
2x difference though right
and Avro is a row based file format as I
was saying before row based file formats
they may not perform that well if you
put it against like a columnar platform
but here's where it gets more
interesting as the right rate so writing
files on HDFS parallely scales really
really well like that we all know for
some time now so if you look at the
right race like it's dominated by
parquet in a row that is like mostly
justifies our reasoning for you know
building it as a job like something as a
library which embeds in your spark
pipelines are supposed to building a
storage system like both things which
have storage systems if you see they
suffer a little bit because like I was
saying before unless you were able to
scale your storage system ask bigger
something like HDFS it's probably not
going to you know perform very well for
right throughput so with us let us try
to understand this is like compare hoody
with two similar systems that we get
asked about a lot and two HBase and
Carew two projects which I personally
have a lot of respect for in terms of
right latency hex places a you know
Honus database right so it gives you
milliseconds of latency
kudos I think is more like Kafka ish
streaming so I can stream data within
like seconds and hoodie for now we're
targeting like you know a few minutes of
latency right because we have a lot of
things to to at uber to bring the world
to even like this point so the HBase Val
is implemented by appends that's what we
use for our own logs to maybe down the
future will sort of approach that for
now you can assume you know one minute
five minute updates one minute insert is
sort of like something practically you
can achieve scan performance like we saw
this already for headspace not optimal
guru has stone column informant which is
optimized which performs pretty well but
who D sticks to the state-of-the-art
Hadoop formats on all of the you know
work that has gone into these formats
you get for free and query engines
HBase how you connector that said presto
doesn't work with HBase as far as I know
and kuru again this I think it works
really well with Impala this is part
connector which I haven't used so I'm
not going to talk more about it but
hoody we've been running it at scale
with hyperstone spark for 4 9 10 months
now and deployment again this is a key
thing extra region servers at least they
are stateless but for kuru you need
specialized storage and you have to like
essentially how to operate a mini HDFS
level of deployment and this is where
hoody for us was like really handy
because we had a ton of spark jobs on
the ecosystem so we just wanted to drop
in a library on a data source where you
can save data incrementally and free
data incremental e on right on top of
HDFS given this most of these are
operational kind of advantages right but
there are like very functional key
features that we built into hoody on
most of them so multirow commits so
hoody by nature being like a mini batch
or a micro batch system does like
multirow chemistry level you can roll
back multiple commands if you try to do
this on top of like HBase or kuru you
have to manage like how you are going to
do to either do this outside yourselves
which can be tedious and in some cases
not even possible
incremental pulls is again something
that we designed ground up to be able to
build like incremental pipelines for
automatic hotspot handling so any
anytime you put a lot of production
pipelines data will skew in different
different shapes and forms so one of the
reasons why we take that extra time
there is to basically we do hotspot
handling where we try to size the files
on HDFS and things like that so we take
that little bit of extra latency do this
book like things well so we can you know
scale as a ecosystem much better we can
drop pipelines into production and they
kind of fly and finally open source who
is a very very young project and we're
looking you know for contributors and we
have a few companies who are like
playing with it
Shopify is trying to use this for
database ingestion into Google out and
we have yearly interest from multiple
companies but engage with the Sun github
look for beginner tasks checkout or
tools utilities please make physicians
and we are indeed hiring for hoodie so
if you're interested you can take a look
at our job posting as well and in terms
of what you can expect when you engage
with the community we have the merchant
Reid project which is kind of nearing
completion but there's still good chunk
of work in terms of production izing it
and whatnot we have the global index
project to build a faster index right
now we use bloom filters to kind of
implement our index so we are looking at
other ways to sort of make it faster as
well as more global and a spark data
source is long-term view we just don't
have resources to put into it and presto
plugins where we can take advantage of
the index to do you know kind of point
lookup equerry very well that's also
something that we would like to do
eventually and finally a beam Runner is
something that we are looking at to
essentially going back to our slide we
won't have a processing pipeline
abstraction and how the user simply
Express the latency and the completeness
and the platform figures out what engine
it can run whether it's going to run in
some streaming engine or a standard
batch engine or on like the hoodie
incremental primitives based on the cost
that you know we can offer this to this
pipeline so that's sort of something
that we we want to do unlike kind of
built at uber finally takeaways um so
hoodie fills we think at least fills a
big void and how to plan by adding a
standardized way to do upsets on kinda
increment get faster data place well
with the existing how do ecosystem
Hadoop is not going away and it's so
building this on Hadoop gains us a lot
more velocity in my opinion and it's
designed ground-up for incremental
processing for example increment opal is
something that we thought about very
deeply before
we got into the implementation that's
pretty much it
Thank You Venus so we have time for a
few questions and after that we can do a
few hours you have any question so my
question was on what you're bringing in
the incremental files you have the
original file and then you have the
second version of that which is as a
second is that a full I guess a CFS file
or is that a you know a abstraction
above that and do if it's an abstraction
do you ever kind of compress it to just
a you know raw HDFS file it is a full
history of us fight okay so the the
abstraction is just the log so
essentially if you we wait til say you
fill up 100 MB of the log then we merge
them and then write a new Park a file so
things the kid keeps going on the
compactor picks the file the file group
with the largest log file and then
decides to come back
that's your second question for the
coefficients you get through so suppose
I have a large data warehouse are
already on the Hadoop in a hive meta
store so if I want to use your framework
so does that mean I have to reprocess
the whole whole data it to to leverage
it is so you have to rewrite it
definitely because we have a index but
you so the way we've done it is we wrote
a utility to scan the first table and
like you know dump it in the hoodie
format then from there on you can do
this increment but a short answer is yes
but what about the fifth street data so
here you have to reprocess them so that
so the answer is basically just develop
the details if you are very sure that
your old partitions are not going to be
in place like they won't get updates in
certs then you can just do it for the
the recent data moving
forward but the minute that you have an
update to like you know on unconverted
partition in hi then it's hoodie is not
going to be able to work because it does
not have the indexing information or
anything to figure things out okay
all right thank you hey so first
question is about Kennedy explosion of
files in the HDFS cluster so Airbnb for
instance we have an average block size
that's that's pretty small and if we
were to use that I think that would be
probably even worse and we've seen
strain on the name node some peers to
see if you have experienced some of that
and then second question is around
whether you guys provide new cities I
would assume I guess for like presto and
hive and and weather I guess you might
want to query the same table with
different surgeries now right so do you
have so it's ready to read get the
latest or an incremental server do so
I'm curious as to how that works okay
all right so first one files so we do so
so just to something that I went up
quickly across is we don't clean the old
versions we do like garbage collector so
so it won't infinitely grow but you're
right in general reexpose so experience
this explosion of files so what that is
also one motivation for merge and read
is so that we can have a much bigger
base file and a log file so I think
doing that's one of the motivations for
even building this projects is to
abstract the storage layer so does it
make sense that's basically the answer I
have it's manageable right now but we
want to get it to a point where like if
you want to store so we're I think gonna
school soon go from petabytes exabytes
so if we do that we want a deterministic
formula and of like a library which like
implements that to say if I want to
store this many petabytes on HDFS and
this is how you do it
and I are back test merge and readers
how we are going to balance the file
sizes inability and the second point is
so right now the all of what
so we still stick to park a study but
the input format we subclass the parking
input format to simply like filter the
files for merge and read we do that in
and also do the record reader but the
record dater ultimately converts it back
into the same Park Authority so pathway
is still like primary so again like we
haven't had a very strong request
outside of football to support new file
format but I think we can simply add two
more files with formats and go there so
the incremental pull the way we do this
is same input format but you set a hive
session flag to say more incremental if
you do that you the query goes into
incremental mode that's a spark client
which lets you do it very natively those
are two ways that we have Ingram so can
you join sound to foody streams sorry
coming help you join on to foodie
streams yeah you can so it's just a high
table at that point so if you buy two
time join then the two streams has time
offsets what do you do like so if they
are not a linked they will not be
aligned perfectly okay so okay something
I want to clear up this hoody does not
change any fundamentals of computing
size and now impossibility raises we
have overcome so in the common technique
people employ is when to stream stream
joints when they are not aligned hoody
can at least give you a look back window
very if you say you always join the last
two hours of data and as long as you can
estimate that you know hey these two
streams won't be out of sync for a like
a maximum bound you can do this and we
have systems in house which track
completeness and latency at like you
know 10 15 minute intervals so we query
that system and sort of do these
finished I think that is a magical
and that would be the last question
I'm Tony how tied you are to changelog
sorts of data coming in as opposed to
just sort of general Kafka streams of
events and you know pressing something
in house strict are the time limitations
so review Kafka streams as just a subset
of change locks so there is an insert
API so if you do inserts you still get
incremental push
so our Kafka data is also going on to
hoody right now the start answer is
roughly okay so okay alerting you
motivating examples so there are big
Kafka topics which are you know to two
terabytes like whatever several
terabytes a day right at that point it's
the same problem again if you are
scanning that one partition over and
over again for finding out what are the
new events you are going to waste and
scan like repeated is can based iOS well
so the incremental pull still helps in
those cases mr. Ransome